Ich möchte millionen menschen sehen die im weltraum arbeiten und dort leben das sind die worte von jeff bezos dem gründer von
Amazon, und blue origin blue origin dass private us raumfahrt
Unternehmen das viele verschiedene, krasse visionen verfolgt, um den weltraum endgültig zu erobern die
Neuesten einblicke dazu gab es jetzt auf einer konferenz in los angeles was plant messers. Und wie weit ist der mit seinen entwicklung
Und er hat, einen revolutionären plan der unsere zivilisation verändern könnte klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Blue origin liefert sich unter anderem mit virgin galactic schon seit längerer zeit, ein spannendes. Kopf-an-kopf-rennen darum
Wer als erstes touristen in den weltraum schicken kann. Und dafür investiert der gründer jeff bezos viel sehr viel sogar es gibt
Anekdoten nach denen der blue origin durch den. Verkauf von. Amazon aktien finanziert und das mit einer milliarde dollar pro
Jahr
Anders als virgin galactic tüfteln die macher von blue origin an einer art
Raumkapsel die durch die news shepherd rakete angetrieben wird in 100 kilometern. Höhe wird die kapsel abgetrennt und schwebt
dann, zur erde möglich machen das fallschirm senkrecht also, ohne erdumrundungen
Und dann in der kapsel am fallschirm hängend wieder zurück damit ließen, sich einige minuten schwerelosigkeit erleben
Einen konkreten preis nennt besser nicht doch wir haben ja vor kurzem berichtet schätzungen zufolge dürften die gibt nicht. Mehr als 50.000 dollar
Kosten und diese kapsel soll tatsächlich. Noch in diesem jahr zum, ersten mal ab ins weltall fliegen
Und zwar bemannt im moment ist sie schon. Mehrmals geflogen. Und besseres hat mit den
Testflügen bereits bewiesen dass seine vision umsetzbar sind die touristen raketen shepherd ist schon fünf geflogen
Und auch wieder sicher auf die erde zurückgekehrt und jeffers ist von seiner vision
Mehr als überzeugt er ist der mann der es geschafft hat. Amazon als größten onlinehändler der welt aufzubauen
Und auch von der konkurrenzfähigkeit seiner raketen ist, er, mehr als überzeugt teilweise ist bessers meinung über die raumfahrt
Und ihre zukunft zu vergleichen mit den ansichten von ihnen maske beide wollen raketen wieder verwendbar machen, so die raumfahrt
Zu einer art low cost produkt machen konkret von raketen demnächst wie heutzutage flugzeuge nur kurz
Zwischenlanden, um inspiziert und aufgetankt zu werden. Dann. Könnten sie, so die vision gleich wieder losfliegen doch
Einen unterschied gibt es schon zwischen den, beiden ländern besser suite sehr geplant. Und langsam schritt für schritt vor zunächst
einmal die kleineren wiederverwendbaren raketen dieses besseres 900 kilometer, hoch bringen sollen
Dann, ist die größere geht die new gm in den startlöchern sie ist je nach version bis zu 95 meter, hoch also
Höher als max rakete falcon heavy nach besser planen könnte sie 45 tonnen in eine niedrige
umlaufbahn schicken immerhin 13 tonnen in eine geostationäre
um
Noch fahren das ist mehr nutzlast als die europäische rakete ariane sechs transportieren kann
Und es gibt bereits kunden die an dem start der new zealand im jahr 2020 interesse angemeldet haben aber auch bemannte. Und unbemannte
Kapseln können sie sie transportieren egal ob richtung mars oder mond die triebwerke der großen
Neuen jänner geht sind sieben schuf starke triebwerke die mit unterstützung der nasa entwickelt werden damit erhoffen
Sich die amerikaner unabhängig von den. Russischen triebwerken. Zu werden die. Bislang die amerikanischen atlas. Raketen antreiben. Danach könnte
Dann, das projekt blue moon realisiert werden. Dabei geht es
um
Eine lieferanten kapsel mit der man den mond
Besiedeln könnte mit dem lande system für den mond sollen bis zu viereinhalb tonnen
Fracht auf den mond gebracht werden und dazu äußerte sich jetzt chef clauses auf der weltraum entwickler. Konferenz ende mai in los angeles
Es ist zeit auf den mond zurückzukehren. Und auch dort zu bleiben sein wunsch sturm mit hilfe. Von esa
Und nasa oder eben einer anderen staatlichen
Weltraumbehörde eine permanente mond siedlung. Zu erbauen doch im fall der fälle sei, er auch bereit seine pläne alleine in die
Tat umzusetzen abgesehen davon träumt, er außerdem von einer revolutionären idee
Industrieanlagen im weltall diese. Könnten 24 stunden am tag durch sonnenenergie angetrieben werden, umweltverschmutzung
Und alle anderen folgen wären von der erde verbannt rohstoffe aus dem all könnten genutzt werden
Und und und der absolute wahnsinn besser spricht in diesem
Zusammenhang von einem zeitraum von jahrzehnten in denen genau das umgesetzt werden kann wenn
Ihr kein video zu den zukünftigen weltraum pläne. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet. Mich bei. What's up?
Dann, umgeht er die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube. Und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten. Auch. Meinen. Schwesterkanal klicks zum
Social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier, kriegen wir aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken neues zeitalter der raumfahrt. Eingeleitet neuer space ex rekord. Bis. Dann
bleibt dran